EVERYONE I WANT TO WELCOME ALL
OF YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION OF A PRO SECOND TODAY.
WE HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR BILLS
ONE OF WHICH IS ON CONSENT.
ARE SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
WE LIKE TO PROCEED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND I SEE THAT MISTER
GRAYSON IS HERE. TO WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL MISTER
GRAYSON [inaudible]
WELCOME. ONE TWO THREE FIVE
WELCOME ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK -- THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR THE HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AND I AM HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE MINUTES AS
PROPOSED.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WILL ENABLE
EIGHT ONE ONE CENTERS TO FULFILL
THEIR STATUTORY -- STATUTORILY
MANDATED DUTY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE BY
NOTIFYING UNDERGROUND FACILITY
OWNERS ABOUT NEARBY EXCAVATION.
WHEN AN EXCAVATOR CALLS AN EIGHT
ONE ONE CENTER THE CENTER IS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
DETAILS OF A DIGGING PROJECT OF
FACILITY OWNERS?
THAT HAVE UNDERGROUND LINES IN
THE VICINITY THE FACILITY OWNERS
WILL THEN SEND A FIELD
TECHNICIAN TO LOCATE AND MARK
THE UNDERGROUND LINES AT THE DIG
SITE.
USING COLORED PAPER FLAGS TO
SHOW LINE LOCATIONS THE
EXCAVATORS CAM THEN YOU SAVE
DIGGING PRACTICES TO AVOID
DAMAGING THE LINES.
HERE AND IS WORTH MORE THE BILL
WORKS UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
SERVICES THE SERVICES IS NOT
REQUIRED. TO SHARE G. -- G. I.
S. MAP DATA WITH THE EIGHT ONE
ONE NOTIFICATION CENTERS.
COUNTY AND STATE G. I. S.
DEPARTMENTS CREATE THE MOST
CURRENT ACCURATE AND THE SORT OF
G. I. S. MET MAP DATA INCLUDING
ADDRESSES ROADS PROPERTY
BOUNDARIES AERIAL PHOTOGRAPHY AT
CETERA.
BY RECKITT OH BY REQUIRING EIGHT
ONE ONE CENTERS TO RECEIVE THE
MOST CURRENT G. I. S. MAPPING
DATA.
AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WILL BENEFIT
ALL STAKEHOLDERS BY PREVENTING
DAMAGE TO UNDERGROUND LINES AND
IN SOME CASES EVEN SAVING LIVES
BY MAKING SURE WE DON'T WRITE
FOR GAS LINES OR OTHER -- OTHER
LINES INTO THE GROUND -- WITH ME
I DO HAVE -- WITNESS FROM USA
NORTH A ONE WELL ALLOW HIM TO
SELF INTRODUCE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROB GROSS CLOUSER REPRESENTING
THE REGIONAL NOTIFICATION CENTER
IN THE NORTH USA NORTH A ONE ONE
I LIKE TO THINK OUR AUTHOR FIRST
COMMITMENT TO THIS MEASURE IT IS
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY MAKING SURE
THAT RGS IDEA IS THE BEST
POSSIBLE.
AND PREVIEWS SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU CAN MATCH AYE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEN AN OPPOSITION.
SCENE AND WHAT'S THE BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED.
WHEN WE WAS WE HAVE A QUORUM
WOULD DO THAT -- BUT WE ARE
REQUIRING IT SO -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CNN -- IS GRAYSON WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES I JUST SIMPLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANKS MUCH ONES
WE HAVE A QUORUM THEN WE WILL --
GET TO IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE
.
AT THIS TIME LET SAYS DALGLISH
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CHAO HERE.
KILEY [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL GALLAGHER [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
SMITH.
WICKS.
YOU HAVE CRIMES ARE WE DO A
QUORUM MY WE DO HAVE ONE ITEM --
THAT'S CONSENT.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO MARK
STONE LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THE CONSENT ITEM HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED TO A MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALDWELL.
ON CONSENT.
CHECK OUT I CHAU I'D KILEY.
BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN I BERMAN
CALDERON.
CALDERON I GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
IRWIN -- WHEN I OBERNOLTE?
OBERNOLTE I'D SMITH.
SMITH I WICKS.
WICKS I CONSENT THE AGENDA IS
ADOPTED. SEVEN SEVEN ZERO LET I
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
MOVE -- AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR TO
BILLS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED UP
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
GRAYSON.
AND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OUT HI JOE I'D KILEY BARRICADE
CAM.
BAUER-KAHAN I BERMAN CALDERON.
CALDERON I GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
IRWIN -- WHEN I OBERNOLTE?
OBERNOLTE EYES SMITH SMITH I
WEEKS WHICH ARE.
AT BILLS OUT THERE ARE SEVEN
ZERO SO FAR WILL LEAD TO OPEN.
THAT LEAVES US WITH. TWO
REMAINING BILLS AND THAT'S AB
FOR FIFTY NINE KILEY IN AB FIVE
NINETY FOUR SALAS -- WILL WAIT
FOR THE OTHERS [inaudible]
TO BE HERE
.
WE ARE BACK ON A NOTICE SAID MR
SALAS HAS JOINED AS SO AT THIS
TIME LIKE TO INVITE HIM UP TO
THE WITNESS TABLE HE HAS A. B.
FIVE NINETY FOUR AND THAT'S ITEM
TO ON OUR AGENDA.
MR SALAS WELCOME IN ANYTIME
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PROCEED.
THE RESEARCHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
FIRST LET ME START BY NOTING
THAT.
THIS IS ONE OF MANY DEALS BILLS
DEALING WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS HERE.
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
AND WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS PROCEDURE STAFF WORK ON
THIS AS WELL -- LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH -- YOURSELF IN THE
OTHER AUTHORS THAT ARE IN THE
SAME SPACE.
AND WE ALL.
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WE'VE LOOKED AT
THIS BUT THEY WILL HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF DIFFERENT TAKES ON IT.
AND I THINK AT THE END OF THE
THE DAY WE'RE ALL JUST TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD FOR
WORKERS GOOD FOR CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY AS WE MOVE INTO THE
SPACE.
AB FIVE READY FOR WITH ESTABLISH
A PROMOTE CALIFORNIA'S ROLE AS A
LEADER IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE BY DESIGNATING A
CHIEF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH AN
ADVISORY COMMISSION ON A AYE
THAT WOULD INCLUDE MEMBERS FOR
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND THEN GLUED A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM ORGANIZED LABOR.
THE COMMISSION WOULD STUDY THE
POTENTIAL USES OF A I AM
DEVELOPING POLICY FRAMEWORK --
THAT WOULD INCLUDE STRATEGIES TO
ONE ESTABLISH AN AN ETHICAL
FRAMEWORK TO MAXIMIZE POTENTIAL
FOR A AYE TO POSITIVELY AFFECT
PEOPLE'S LIVES THREE UTILIZE A
AYE -- FOR STATE FUNCTIONS FOR
EDUCATE AND TRAIN STUDENTS AND
WORKERS IN A AYE. FIVE ANALYZE A
MINIMIZE ANY ADVERSE IMPACTS
WORKERS.
IN ADDITION THE CHIEF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER WOULD
ADVISE A CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
IN EVALUATING WORKFORCE
EDUCATION TRAINING AN ADVISER
DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY IN
EVALUATING THE ISSUES OF A AYE
AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO.
NOT AN OVERALL PLAN FOR HOW THE
STATE SHOULD USE A AYE NOR THEIR
FRAMEWORKS AND HOW TO REPAIR
WORKERS AND STUDENTS FOR THE
COMING CHANGES TO THE ECONOMY.
IN A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA THIS
IS.
OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE
ESPECIALLY WITH -- THE SILICON
VALLEY AND OUR GLOBAL LEADERSHIP
IN THIS INDUSTRY AND IN THE
SECTOR AND THEN -- THIS REGION A
I HAS THE POTENTIAL TRANSFORM
EVERY SEGMENT OF OUR LIVES IN
THE ECONOMY AFTER THIS
TREMENDOUS UPSIDES.
AN ENORMOUS BENEFITS -- WITH
THAT THE BILL HAS OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'VE.
THANKS VERY MUCH -- WHEN THIS IS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD?
I HAVE MORE COMMON SPENCERPORT
OUR OPPOSITION -- NEEDS THE
VARIOUS WITH SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND REPRESENTING NINETY SIX
THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THIS BILL WOULD IMPACT OBVIOUSLY
SOME OF THE WORK FORCE -- JUST
JUST I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- SALAS FOR FOR BRINGING
TO THE ATTENTION -- THAT THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE MANY BILLS
OUT THERE IN THERE ARE GOING TO
BE IMPACTS ON THE WORK FORCE.
AND CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE A
LEADER IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S A MATTER OF IF WE ARE BUT
IT'S IT'S A MATTER OF WHAT CAN
WE DO WHAT SHOULD WE DO.
AND HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
THE WORK FORCE IS -- YOU KNOW
INVOLVED IN SOME OF THE
DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING MADE
WHEN IT COMES TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE SO THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
ALL IN OPPOSITION OR SOMEWHERE
IN BETWEEN.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COME AS MISTER
CALDERON GUY.
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAUCE FOR
WAITING IN THE SUBJECT MATTER I
HAVE AN AYE AYE BILL THAT I'M
WORKING ON SETTING UP WORKING
GROUP I KNOW THAT -- THE CHAIR
HAS BEEN WORKING ON A AYE ISSUES
FOR A LONG TIME BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE THE DIFFERENT
LEVELS ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
I AM VERY LITTLE TO NO
REGULATION OVER THE SUBJECT
MATTER AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF BIG COMPANIES THAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO BE CREATIVE
AND INNOVATIVE BUT ALSO AT THE
SAME TIME.
WE WANT TO AVOID IS THE
OPPORTUNITY OR I SHOULD SAY
OPPORTUNITY THE THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF SOMETHING BEING
CREATED BY A COMPANY THAT CANNOT
BE TAKEN BACK -- AND ONCE
SOMETHING IS ON THE WORLDWIDE
WEB YOU CANNOT YOU CAN YOU CAN'T
TURN OFF WHICH YOU CAN'T YOU
CAN'T TAKE THAT BACK -- AND SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS A GOOD STEP
WHEN IT COMES TO HELPING THE
STATE REGULATE.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WE NEED
TO BE THE LEADER BECAUSE WE ARE
THE TECH -- NOT JUST THIS
COUNTRY BUT OF THE WORLD -- SO
IT IS ON US TO CREATE THE
STANDARD OF REGULATION WHEN IT
COMES TO ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE --
WE NEED TO BE PAYING ATTENTION
IN THAT AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LEVEL OF HESITATION WHEN IT
COMES TO THE COMPANIES.
THAT ARE WORKING ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO KNOW THAT -- WE
ARE PAYING ATTENTION AND WHAT
THEY DO AND HOW THEY USE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS
IMPORTANT AND YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW ASKING QUESTIONS SUCH
AS IF I AM.
LOOKING UP SOMETHING POLITICAL.
BECAUSE I HAVE CERTAIN GOOGLE
SEARCHES THROUGH THAT MEAN THAT
I SHOULD CONTINUE TO SEE THE
THINGS THAT I THAT.
WHATEVER ALGORITHM ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS IN PLACE ONCE
BELIEVES I WANT TO SEE OR SHOULD
I BE SEEING WHATEVER COMES UP
NATURALLY BECAUSE MAYBE IT'S
HEALTHY THAT I GET.
A DOSE OF THE OTHER SIDE NOT
JUST ONLY ONE SIDE OF THINGS SO --
I THINK THAT HAVING SOME TYPE OF
REGULATION -- LEAST WITH NO IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S PROPOSED -- IN
YOUR BILL ALONG WITH A COUPLE
THE OTHER BILLS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED -- IS IMPORTANT SO I'M
GONNA MOVE YOUR BILL AND I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR WORKING IN THE
SPACE I APPRECIATE THAT IT JUST
COMMENT I MEAN THIS IS WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE A CHIEF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OFFICER.
ME WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOUR
TALK ABOUT ALGORITHMS AND JUST
HOW THAT WORKS I MEAN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT'S AND FOR INSTANCE RIGHT
AND HOW THAT'S CHANGING --
SEARCH AND SEARCH ENGINES WHEN
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE OTHER
COMPANIES THAT YOU LISTED LIKE
FACEBOOK AND SOME OF THE OTHERS
THAT I'VE DELVED INTO I AM.
A HIGH.
I MEAN WE SHOULD ALL BE ALARMED
WHEN A I WAS TALKING TO EACH
OTHER AND REINVENTING THE
LANGUAGE.
AND KEEPING US OUT AS HUMANS.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
MEANT I MEAN WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME PARAMETERS SOME FRAMEWORK
SOME GUIDING PRINCIPLES AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HOPING.
TO HELP GUIDE THAT DISCUSSION
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE MOTION.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
SALAS THANK YOU.
FOR OFFERING THE BILL AND PROUD
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE DOING GOOD WORK HERE --
JUST HAD ONE KIND OF CAUTION AND
AS YOU KNOW I'M I'M NOT AN
EXPERT IN A I BUT I DID RESEARCH
ON A AYE IN GRADUATE SCHOOL.
I'VE CODED.
YEAH I SYSTEMS.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE IN
YOUR BILL OUR OUR FINAL BAFFLING
LIKE -- THERE'S THERE'S A PHRASE
HERE ONE OF THE THE BULLET
POINTS IS THAT A AYE SYSTEM
SHOULD BE DESIGNED.
AND OPERATED IS TO BE COMPATIBLE
WITH CULTURAL DIVERSITY.
AND I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT BUT I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU
MEAN.
FROM A TECHNICAL STANDPOINT AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN WE
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT A AYE TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT A AYE ISN'T
WHAT IT IS NOT BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF CONFUSION OUT THERE -- I
THINK THAT TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THINK THE A I HAVE SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO SOMETHING THAT THEY
SAW ON THE JETSONS.
RIGHT AND THE REALITY IS THE A.
I. AS MUCH MORE SUBTLE THAN THAT.
AND SO I I JUST THINK IT'S IT'S
A VERY SUPPORTIVE OF OF YOU KNOW
STUDYING THIS ISSUE FURTHER BUT
I'M NOT SUPPORTIVE OF DOING OF
MAKING STATEMENTS THAT.
THAT ARE GONNA COULD FOR FURTHER
CONFUSE PEOPLE CORRECT YEAH NOW
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS JUST TRY TO HAVE SOME
GUIDING PRINCIPLES THAT -- LIVID
TO SOCIETAL NORMS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY MUCH BETTER WAY OF
PUTTING IT -- I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU JUST SAID -- BUT ANYWAY
PLEASE PLEASE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY THANKS FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH -- I YOU KNOW
I'M VERY EXCITED BECAUSE I YOU
KNOW I'M SEEING A LOT OF IT A
BILLS ON A I'D ONLY FROM THE
ASSEMBLY BUT ALSO FROM THE
SENATE SIDE.
SO -- MY YOU KNOW THE REASON I'M
SO EXCITED BECAUSE WE WANT
CALIFORNIA TO BE YOU KNOW RIGHT
UP THERE -- IF NOT AHEAD OF THE
CURVE AT LEAST TO YOU KNOW BE A
PART OF THE CURVE SO -- SO I YUP
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THERE MAY
BE SOME OVERLAP BETWEEN YOUR
BILL AND SOME OF THE I'LL BILLS
OUT THERE.
AND MIGHT MY INCLINATION IS TO
SEE THE BILL GO FORWARD.
A BECAUSE THIS IS ONLY THE FIRST
COMMITTEE THE BILL AS AN SO I
WANT TO SEE.
THE BILL MORE FOR TODAY WE COULD
DO SOME RECONCILIATION AND
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD ONCE WE
HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE
SENATE BILLS ALSO TO SEE WHAT
THEY ARE WHAT THEY WHAT THEY DO.
ON SO BUT I DO YOU KNOW ALL ONE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOU KNOW
BASICALLY AGREED TO WORK WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS GOING
FORWARD.
AT SOME POINT WE NEED TO ALL
KIND OF SIT DOWN AND KIND OF MAP
OUT SOME YOU KNOW.
GET ALL THE CONFLICT OUT OF THE
THE DIFFERENT BILLS I KNOW YOU
HAVE YOUR BILL HOUSE -- SOME
FEATURES SAID TO DO OVERLAP WITH
OTHER EXISTING GOES BUT THE
THERE ARE OTHERS FOR EXAMPLE
THAT.
THE CHIEF FOR A AYE OFFICER IS
WHICH IS VERY UNIQUE -- SO ON SO
WE CAN ALL SIT DOWN AT SOME
POINT TO YOU KNOW SORT IT ALL
OUT SO.
AS LONG AS I HAVE YOUR
COMMITMENT I'M I'M VERY
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT LIKE THIS SAID THERE'S
SEVERAL BILLS AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE THERE'S SOME
ASPECTS OF THIS BILL THAT ARE
NOT ANOTHER SALES AND SO IF WE
CAN ALL COME TOGETHER.
DO THE RIGHT THING I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO THE ABSOLUTE ONE OF
WHICH IS THE DEFINITION OF A AYE
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THE DEFINITION OF A AYE
IN ANY OF THE BILL SO.
THAT'S BEEN POINTED OUT IN THE
ANALYSIS ALSO SO WITHOUT THE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
APPRECIATED I'VE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION.
VERY GOOD DUBBED BILLS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED THE BILL WILL
GO TO ASSEMBLY LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT NEXT -- SO WITHOUT
THE MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
OUT HI SO I KILEY.
KILEY I'VE BAUER-KAHAN
BAUER-KAHAN HI BERMAN.
CALDERON.
CALDERON HI GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER IRWIN -- WHEN I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE SMITH?
SMITH I WEEKS.
WEEKS I HIS HOUSE SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. EIGHT ZERO
EXCUSE ME A TWO ZERO SO THAT
LEAVES -- VICE CHAIR KILEY SPELL --
IS KILEY HAS AB.
FIVE FOUR FIFTY NINE THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONTINUING WITH OUR A A
HIGH THEME.
I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FIFTY NINE AND I'D
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- AS YOU
MAY KNOW LAST FALL THE LITTLE
WHO WERE COMMISSION RELEASED THE
REPORT TITLED ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE A ROAD MAP FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION
REFER TO THE REPORT AS A CALL TO
ACTION -- THAT'S ONE REASON I'VE
INTRODUCED AB FOR FIFTY NINE
WHICH PASSED THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND STATE SERVICES
COMMISSION WITH CREATING A SET
OF GUIDELINES AND STANDARDS FOR
THE USE OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED ITSELF AS A LEADER
IN A POLICY IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
MY RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
ASYLUM ARE A I PRINCIPLES.
A SET OF GUIDELINES FOR THE SAFE
AND BENEFICIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
USE OF A AYE.
THAT RESOLUTION ACR TO FIFTEEN
WAS ONLY THE FIRST STEP IN
ACKNOWLEDGING THE IMPORTANCE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WITHIN
SOCIETY AND OUR ROLE AS STATE
LAWMAKERS.
AB FOR FIFTY NINE BILLS ON THAT
RESOLUTION BY ENSURING THAT
FUTURE USES OF A AYE TOOLS WITH
IN CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT
OR MANAGE THEM AMENDED IN A FAIR
SECURE ETHICAL AND BENEFICIAL
MANNER.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE ACT TO
STAY AHEAD OF THE CURVE AND BE
PREPARED TO RESPONSIBLY EMBRACE
THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS KILEY.
WHEN THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THE BILL TO IN MOVED AND
SECONDED TO LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU YEAH I'M GONNA
JUST -- JUST BRIEFLY A REPEAT
WHAT I AS I TOLD MR SALAS AND
YOU KNOW I I LOOK FOR TO THIS IS
THIS IS A VERY GOOD BILL --
BECAUSE IT REALLY COMPLIMENTS --
YOU KNOW THE OTHER EXISTING GOES
OUT THERE AND I YOU KNOW.
I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE A AYE BILLS TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY CONFLICTS
THAT WE CAN CUT.
RECONCILE INTO THE FUTURE SO
WITH THAT.
I'M SECRETARY THE BILL WILL GO
TO NEXT TO ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SHALL I TELL AYE KILEY AYE KILEY
AYE BY BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I BERMAN.
BERMAN HI CALDERON.
CALDERON HI GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
IRWIN -- WHEN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE SMITH?
SMITH I WEEKS.
WEEKS AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NINE TWO ZERO SAID THAT --
BASICALLY IS ALL THE BILLS THAT
WE HAVE TODAY THIS TIME I LIKE.
TO I'LL GO OVER THE CALENDARS TO
BASICALLY -- ALLOW MEMBERS TO
ADD ON TO THE BILLS STARTING
LET'S START START WITH THE
CONSENT AGENDA -- PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
KILEY HI KILEY ONLINE
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
ALL RIGHT -- WHATEVER IS
[inaudible]
I WOULD.
CARTER -- I'M IT BERMAN. NINE
ZERO THAT -- CONSENT ITEM IS OUT.
LET'S GO.
LET'S GO BACK OUT TO THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA [inaudible]
EVERYBODY.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FOR
FIFTY NINE WE JUST GOT THROUGH
THAT.
ONE EVERYBODY. TWO MISSING OKAY
VERY GOOD THE ITEM NUMBER TWO A.
B. FIVE NINETY FOUR SALAS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BERMAN.
HI.
THIS.
NINE ZERO THE BILL IS NINE ZERO
WE STILL HAVE A COUPLE MORE
MEMBERS -- LET'S -- TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
GRAYSON PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS KILEY.
KILEY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
ALSO.
OUR HOUSE SO.
YOU VOTED.
YEAH.
THE FIRST.
I WAS THE FIRST BILL
.
LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR ADD ONS --
LET'S GO TO THE TOP OF THE
AGENDA.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FOR FIFTY
NINE KILEY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
SO GALLAGHER I HATE THE THOUGHT.
I ELEVEN ELEVEN ZERO ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B.
FIVE NINETY FOUR SALAS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I LIVE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
ELEVEN ZERO LET'S GO TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
GRAYSON PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I AND AND FINALLY LETS
GO TO CONSENT AGENDA WHICH HOUSE
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO STONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I LET THAT'S ELEVEN
ZERO AS WELL THANK YOU MEMBERS
THAT -- WILL DO IT FOR OUR
MEETING MEETING ADJOURNED